this is a another another probably not
right right it's the second one the
morning coffee show I'm having my early
morning coffee and I'll try to wake up
getting some coffee into my system and
playing a bit of chassis only chess I
think I'm going for them I would is
super blitz arena as I usually do I get
many games and now the alternative is
actually the hour the Blitz with five
minute games but let's do let's go or
three minutes and see what happens I'm
joining a bit late I like a minute late
okay not a big deal I just say it's like
to ten ten in the yuning 10:00 in the
morning I'm not yet awake okay so let's
see Harry Sale is my opponent probably
will get a scotch game no but after 93
it's possible so this is a good good
line for white yeah there's a good
question by dawn in the chat
when I reached reached partner status
I'm not yet a twitch partner but I'm a
twitch affiliate now they offered or
they they send me message today that I'm
qualified and I'm actually now able to
yeah is it's right to say cold it's good
to say I'm yeah that I can get
subscriptions
it's what I'm trying to save so if you
like to support me streaming you can
subscribe to this channel okay here I'm
trying to get this bishop on the long
diagonal and I'm succeeding and this is
a nice position for white white is
always going to be slightly better here
with the bishop mmm you know it's just
not so easy to make something
out of it something concrete
I'm still suffering a bit here on c2
okay so he's opening up the position
kind of counter-intuitively against the
bishops but d6 was a weak parts of I
understand his idea let's see if rookie
one it looks very nice but the structure
is entirely symmetrical doesn't make it
so easy probably going to go see form
yeah I can yeah this is actually quite
good see form the night goes to f6 I
take everything no it doesn't do that
but this is also not bad I go here and
go rookie seven after Knight f6 I would
have taken and then maybe rookie seven
here the same drink is quite annoying
rook c8 has Bishop e5 you know he has to
do that I guess yes account to play with
rook oh I thought work t2 that looks
like no counter play no counter play at
all now the b-pawn should should be
enough to win this so one key m9 a for
Bishop d4
oh okay so taking yeah but it's City to
take this piece it's really not good
let's not take it good morning to cool
out yes I'm fine thanks for asking I
hope you are fine as well is it morning
hours your time or it could be really
late like us some UE u.s. west coast
there could be really late in the day or
early depending on
how you how you see it okay here like a
1 a.m. in Los Angeles I guess oh yeah
San Diego yes so a bishop a 7a that
should be the rook I should get that
rook
yeah uh-huh
so - and what is that that's not that's
not Texas right that's seven hours what
is that Texas snow a little bit said
Nevada or something - mm a Utah okay so
we've got two scotch four nights with
black yeah I often have that with the
white pieces aha
and he goes with the the Belgrade gambit
this is not a good line for white but I
only know that night before is good but
I have essentially four button wife okay
Jake
probably not the toughest continuation
here but I mean it must be okay I want
to go d6 and I don't want to keep the
bishop inside of this like only seven
okay he's doing something something
funky
it should be fire it could be an
annoying pin so I'm going to going to go
h 6e m yaki f1 is not bad it's not so
terrible you can you can do and how he
plays it I thought you just wanted to
avoid this thing this trait but okay
okay
why this fine of course he's got good
space and everything it's a good way to
put it here this is the spawn structure
here this is quite okay for white it's
quite favorable I'm going to try to
arrest them a little bit death with this
pieces good morning to Hornish ducks I
know you are in Germany so yeah I can
really say good morning
it's right okay Queen to e7 I should
have to be a bit cautious a look in the
middle okay
well that looks kind of okay my pieces
are active that pawn structure he is
again it's not so great in some cases
you can go like c4 before and and attack
this I cannot move any of the points
yeah c6 would leave weaknesses b6 would
leave weaknesses so yeah this is a kind
of okay for white but the thing that
overrides everything is his Luke is not
playing him yes streaming before
breakfast that's actually true I that's
that's the first thing I happen the
system here the coffee
okay so he wants to play the rook rook
e1 is there any way to prevent that
night h5 rook e1 queen man I don't know
I can't take on them I can take on d5
but still as rook e1 queen age five yeah
it's it's something I can't play I think
G for Queen h4
this is not entirely clear it really
isn't if I go Knight f6 next
there's Ruby 7 I would probably go C 6
yeah ok yeah I can just take a 5 right
with Queen
one thing that is of course helping is
that I'm probably going to win this on
time because he's not really quick ok
check yeah probably taking us the
easiest and this will be decided by the
clock he's got no time I know
it was fall yeah that was interesting
they were interesting unconventional
game so what's going on now who is in
this tournament a couple of people with
higher my rating is this terrible like
mm something 2200 heavily underrated
probably I don't know Bishop e7 okay and
- Bishop f6 okay
this is probably what is that
I can sum or display the material
difference here okay isn't that I've
never done that isn't that clogging our
screen space I'm where would that be
like on the screen where where is that
placed I think I mean if you think it's
helpful for you I think you should try
to do it without and simply get get this
yeah get this into your system to do in
terms without any help let's say okay
I'm trying to double on the e-file oh I
got 100
I got she is okay thank you I think FF
Devin's set that up correctly with the
cheers okay so I'm a little bit quicker
on them on the e-file here but it is not
much obviously let's see I can go Queen
B 5 could be five actually a little bit
annoying because Queen d7 is the natural
reply and then London c7 oh my god watch
yes thank you I have to actually check
that out what what that what that does
okay he has given me c7 probably not
entirely loved not was not attended okay
I'm this is important I'm fixing the
pawn on d6 so then it stays a weakness
and the 9th year has to be regrouped
night on b3 is terrible okay this is a
good idea playing be five but the I have
control of this
so this is basically like I'm like a
donation okay thank you I have to
understand twitch better I'm really new
here okay playing less shop and let's
show this is leading this okay let's go
for Sicilian playing with Kalashnikov
okay it's not a very testing response
because Blackie gets this this pin on
the road I just wondered sometimes I've
seen there are gambit continuations I
[Music]
take here 94 Bishop b5 Queen to e7 is
that good
yeah like Bishop e5 Queen e7 Bishop g7
93 I got another chair I have to make
this a little bit smaller thank you
the shaved eyebrow look and no I don't
think so never try dad okay what's going
on here Queenie - an interesting move
probably a good move I can take a five
and then Queen checks you know
hmm okay I'm taking after thank you fun
it's not much else I can plain I have
six or so but that doesn't doesn't do
much and here's a checking my my night I
can take that doesn't doesn't lead you
all that much it's mmm yeah it's tough
to not take on e4 really I cannot cancel
and if I move the deep one there's
Bishop of course yeah you're completely
right yeah when he talks is right of
course I can take here here and Queenie
a5 create five yeah you know I I simply
I didn't see Queenie - I was thinking I
would win anyway I just overlooked Queen
e2
[Music]
you know this is not this is probably
just equal the time doesn't look good
the time doesn't look good I've been
thinking too long about all this but at
least it's a reasonably simple rook
endgame
maybe it's nice and gives me an H pawn
here he does okay here we go so just
just move the pawns check and then take
the open file so this is this is nice
Oh what made me want to start learning
chess I don't think it is such a we
cannot just tell me I mean you did you
just start at some point yeah because
it's it's somehow interesting to you I
mean I knew the rules some pretty early
on but I only played later when it
somehow was some yeah I don't know at
least and in my youth it was like me and
my friends we we were going through
different games that was and one time it
was like billiards and it was darts and
it was chess at some point and yeah
winning this rook him and it just like
enjoyed it a lot and yeah this this was
how it's how it started and then I
joined the chess group at my school and
then the club and so on
so here tired tired I cannot pronounce
those names a dot stream hey that's that
sounds like fun
I always like to play darts and I mean
I'm not I'm not good but I'm not totally
terrible and you know if I would have
put some time into it I could have could
have been somewhat decent I think
probably talking nonsense but
just like people sometimes say I have a
decent chess player and then they barely
know the rules but yeah I think I'm not
totally terrible I would invest a bit of
time Knight f6 I can take the 70 key six
that's always going to be slightly
better I'm not in Bavaria we have to be
precise there and the various is a part
of Germany but it's not the part I live
in so I'm yeah he either takes only six
now with this pawn or he gives me yeah
I'm gonna pawn up now which is okay it's
an okay opening result my development is
not great absolutely not so let's get
this out oops
yeah 94 95 okay he prevents that not bad
so get it to f3 let's see I'm going to
need the King King e2 now doesn't do
much actually the way it is I think I
wouldn't mind to trade him and the
stream is not going to be super long
because I have to have to do some stuff
for this before hmm
I don't like it so much what I did here
King e2 is checking me you know anyway
after it have to do it
you know it was a bit silly how I played
this it's still pretty good because I'm
half the king in the center and so on
but still I probably they were easier
ways to play this simpler ways
Brooksie one is that possible yam Bishop
g5 doesn't do much after rook trade I
would win very very easily so I've got
the D file and now I can try to improve
the night and same I hope d5 of course
that was sick I could have just played
route d5 very simple and yeah the best
way to learn tactics is just doing them
fall over yeah just do exercises to
puzzles and it's just important to do it
on a very regular basis it doesn't have
to be I mean doing it as often as
possible
it's good yeah you're just important to
do it on a steady basis say if you do
like you know two hours one day and then
don't do anything we gets better to do
yeah every day a little bit it's a
little bit like you would be training
let's say for a long distance run in
like a marathon you also would would do
daily yeah you would do daily runs or at
least I've never done that yeah but yeah
you have would have some kind of
schedule that you do it very regularly
and it's the same thing by doing it all
over again those patterns sink in more
and and most of the tactics you will see
almost automatically so here I'm going
to yeah treat the brain like a muscle
that's a good a good way to put it
yeah I saw this in fact and there's the
check here going to going to win all the
pawns
and cover f2 at the same time with the
night okay this is I'm going for
checkmate him yep always good to win my
major games over then no complicated
things to to master if you made the guy
okay el caballero doing good job him
seems like he's running away with it a
little bit it would be good if I would
play him but even Daniel it seems he is
winning quite quickly
okay and it wasn't a good opening I was
somewhat irritated like the berserk of
course okay it's funky how do you get
that back yeah not like that okay should
know no we should pay three or something
it's not not good okay update the
Serbian center Klaus good morning so how
does he even know so that was nice yeah
that was really important getting five
points and catching up it seems Iike
Barrow has done two berserks at the very
beginning and I didn't do that
so that is why is ahead but we still
have like 30 minutes to go and it would
be nice to get a game against him too
no mr. Walker but mr. Bokka is also
quite hydrated
keep forgetting the theory
oops the way to do this and it's funky
that that almost everybody plays this
against me and money the most always go
Bishop d6 who is the strongest player
you've ever beaten over the board yeah
[Music]
the strongest player I've beaten over
the board is Mikhailovich
it's a grandmaster originally from from
the Ukraine and now playing he played
for Turkey for a while and for Belgium
so he switched federations quite a bit
why is it a strong player his best
ranking was number five in the world at
the time I beat him he wasn't as strong
anymore but still a very very good
player he was roughly 2600 at the time
and that was funny enough actually the
first Grandmaster they left beaten so
and I have won also against a two
thousand six hundred two years ago
Alexander coughed Sean also from Ukraine
it was a nice one actually a nice game I
featured that on my channel at some
point ok quick to c6 seems like he wants
to go for b5 even he wasn't the 2,700 at
the time he was a he had lost some
rating but he is a really really strong
player very knowledgeable
I was always it was very M it was a
really interesting experience to
actually play against him because I had
studied so many games of him yeah he has
beaten Anand and and everybody else
basically at at one point he was a
second to honored for some years so that
was really cool I think I still think
I mostly won that game because he had a
huge hangover it really felt like you
had a hangover and sometimes you feel
this
fighting for the e-file him
I didn't I did not register that I was
stupid okay I have to be quicker there
was a stupid mistake okay I'm better
again because he cannot prevent rooty 7
which is maybe not the end of the world
actually yeah can go before maybe now
it's still equal the time time situation
is a little bit a little bit of putting
him 29 seconds Bishop c5 I'm threatening
this no no one's not threatening it it's
so a bit annoying here okay it's a
completely winning ending
but how yeah probably
this I only have four freaking seconds
and he's been winning this this on time
how annoying there's a super complete
completely winning game yeah okay
and that was silly that was extremely
slim should have just sped up early I'm
losing is pretty terrible this game yeah
it's a huge setback just a bit four
points instead of zero I heard I also
also only recognized really late that it
was oh I didn't want to play the French
there was a mouse slip okay
I only realized that far too late that
I'm actually then actually so far behind
on the clock that actually happens to me
quite frequently and I should somehow
stop it I don't know how actually but I
have this quite often that in those
games I all over Sun recognize oh my god
I don't have any time left and then it's
simply it's simply too late okay this is
going to be most likely a quick win
[Music]
Luke g1 mate would be good to get in yep
so that compensated a little bit a
little bit okay co-op says he cannot win
Queen worlds rook and Knight and Bishop
made me yeah
it's o that I have to focus now in a
cabaret role let's go for the throat
this is actually a very interesting
opening g5 it looks a bit wacky yeah
okay he threatening now
akia takes on deform so I have to cover
this
maybe you can take narrow him on g5 then
II five I don't know very tough but okay
I wanted I wanted a sharp game and I got
it yes I was asked I was thinking about
this him
if this is an option for him activating
the Queen like that
he's now threatening maybe discoveries
here with the night a night is 6m 97's
96
Knight f6 is plundering a pawn I would
together I would like to cancel though
okay it's it's maybe it's lucky but I
have to make a decision in three minutes
yes okay it doesn't take it may be
because he thinks I cannot cancel anyway
that's a really really tough tough game
no again I cannot cancel
energy seven was hanging I couldn't take
this was temple that's a very very tough
tough kind of game
he cannot take d3 would I know I
actually can check d3 does look a tune
maybe I should simply speed up I mean
okay trying to say okay this is a
the night is offside I should speed up
he's taking time for every single move
no if I get night Stewie 5 and C 5 then
I'm somewhat okay but he just prevented
that age 3 is a bit surprising this this
frame thing has no square
ig2 actually I should play f6 and jam
then
f6 is an interesting move doesn't do it
[Music]
okay that was a really somewhat strange
game a really tough game I have to say I
was going on down so let's see volume oh
this is not a good porn structure
it really isn't
yeah this is actually now a simple plan
you just trade down everything and win
the ending okay
okay so go here
q
and now everything is safe on the on the
queenside now I can move the kingside
pawns I think
oh this is berserk totally forgot about
that
I want 20 seconds okay viewers
tournament for fun yeah I'm thinking
about other formats ready I'm not so
thinking about sea mules and things like
el caballero
again and I've got black okay so I'm
going to good na d3 and you play d3 you
just have to go to six or ninety six not
this moving too quickly yeah this is
really bad
that's really bad I don't think these
three is a good move to be honest and
now I'm justifying it I know this
position is unplayable for black almost
I wanted to play quickly
[Music]
isn't that okay for me almost play 90
for him 19 Luke takes five that's very
close to working actually
and nights 96 assesses just extremely
annoying and I know not a bit not a move
you want to play
anyway
very weird way of playing everything
here I've got three points but white is
still better he's got this exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I really don't care how that work
but no III it's not a bad move I mean
bad move is too strong but this is a
line that is quite often recommended
this to d3 and I don't think it's I
don't think it's it's it's really
dangerous it's just like 90 f6 which I
was basically pre moving as as is this
this is the only way to really make it
there was to lay down his irking okay I
wanted to it's one of the very few ways
of making this line look good
if the attorney said yeah it's just
completely and you don't see the rest
yet it's just like the whole the whole
chat is this stuff yeah with the away I
mean at least I don't understand it
certainly it is a language it's not just
complete coverage but I have no clue
what they're talking about it could be
could be Turkish yes that's true or
maybe em what's that called I think it's
also Turkey and what term caught Turk
what am speaking Azerbaijan okay so I'm
getting closer but I'm still hip four
points behind follow the Turkish and
Azaria okay
so four points behind if I could be
paired against mr. Marek at least
there's a chance to win quickly I mean
also a chance to lose courtly word but
why key this this opening play were
black
you six but okay that's really losing
the house okay Wow so that was a good
five points all of a sudden I'm in the
lead so maybe I can get another quick
win in the books come on give me 96 mate
come on and would have been fantastic
again this is difficult but I have to
have to play the position a little bit
you cannot just do something completely
crazy even if you want to win quickly of
course you still have to play some more
decent moves
what Wow
come on resign then I'm completely
completely in this again I actually
finds a good move crap
come on let me get this into books that
would be great
I'm winning even more stuff here the
night I don't see how he saves it
he doesn't okay
we have one next male going on to have
seven six
hmm one minute left
want to go rook g5 and I can let the
clock run down now come morning
really no come on resign yes yes Wow I
[Music]
stole that completely on the finishing
line ha ha that's nice winning to
berserks at the end wow I didn't expect
that to happen but at the end here to to
to preserve wins did it Wow nice nice
and I just have finished my coffee so
everything everything works out it works
out really really well
ok guys I'm going to wrap it up I just
wanted to make this this quick stream
happen if you enjoy those streams and
like to support me you can subscribe to
the channel it's a nice way to get me to
stream stream more and regularly I will
also figure out some benefits yeah for
the for the subscribers of course it is
totally new to me I have to check what I
can do with this I know I can do things
slap subscriber only streams or just
let's say play em play subscribers in a
unless in a dedicated show or things
like that but there are also other
things you can do with subscriptions so
would be great it would be great to see
more people subscribing to the channel
it works like yesterday it works yeah
thanks a lot for watching I'll be back
soon enough and by the way I wanted to
mention there is a stream today also on
for chest 24 I'm doing doing them
doing the stream for chess 24 this
evening this is 7:00 p.m. Central
European Time yeah thanks a lot for
watching bye bye